so let's see if we can take the
derivative of this expression right over
here if we can find capital F prime of X
and once again it looks like you might
be able to use the fundamental theorem
of calculus the big giveaway is that
you're taking the derivative of a
definite integral that gives you a
function of X but here I have X on both
the upper and the lower boundary and the
fundamental theorem of calculus at least
for them what we've seen it it's when we
have X is only on the upper boundary
then of course it's an x squared and but
we've seen examples of that already when
we use the chain rule to do it but how
can we break this up and put this in a
form that's a little bit closer to what
we're familiar with when we apply the
fundamental theorem of calculus and to
realize that we really just have to
attempt to graph what this is
representing so let's say that this is
our lower case f of X or I should say f
of T so let's get called this lower case
F of T and let's graph it over the
interval between X and x squared so
let's say this is my Y axis this is my t
axis and let's say that this right over
here is y is equal to f of T I'm drawing
it generally I don't know what this
exactly looks like and we're going to
talk about the interval between x and x
squared so if we're going to talk about
the interval between X which is right
over here so lower bound so x and x the
square it's the lower bound at least for
this definite integral we don't know for
sure it depends on what x you choose on
which one is actually smaller but let's
just say that right for the sake of
visualizing we'll draw X right over here
and we will draw will draw x squared
right over here x squared right over
here so this whole expression this
entire definite integral is essentially
asking for is essentially representing
the this entire area the entire area
under under the curve but what we could
do is introduce a constant that's
someplace in between X and x squared
let's say that constant is C and break
this area into two different areas with
C as the divisor so that same exact
whole area we can now write it as two
separate integrals so one integral that
represents this area right over here and
then another integral that
this area right over there and we just
say C is some constant between X and x
squared well how can we denote this area
in purple well that's going to be so
this thing is going to be equal to the
sum of these two areas the purple area
is going we can show is the definite
integral from X to C of our function of
T cosine T over T DT and then to that
we're going to add the green area and
then we'll get the original area so the
green area for the green area our lower
bound of integration is now our constant
C and our upper bound of integration is
x squared it's going to be of cosine T D
over T cosine T over T DT and this is a
form where if we if we know how to apply
the chain rule we can apply the
fundamental theorem of calculus and this
is almost in a form we're used to seeing
it where the X is the upper bound now
what we already know what happens we can
swap these two bounds but it will just
be the negative of that integral so this
is going to be equal to let me rewrite
it the negative the negative of the
definite integral from C to X of cosine
T over T DT and then we have plus the
definite integral that goes from C to x
squared
of cosine T cosine T over T DT so all
we've done is we've rewritten this thing
in a way that it's we're used to
applying the fundamental theorem of
calculus so if we want to find F prime F
prime of X well applying the derivative
operator over here we're going to have a
negative up front it's going to be equal
to negative cosine X over X cosine X
over X once again just the fundamental
theorem of calculus and then plus we're
first going to take the derivative of
this thing with respect to x squared and
that's going to give you cosine of x
squared over x squared wherever you saw
t you replace it with an x squared and
then you're going to multiply that times
the derivative of x squared with respect
to X so that's just going to be
the derivative of x squared with respect
to X is just 2x and we're done
we just need to simplify this thing so
all of this is going to be equal to
negative cosine x over X plus well this
is going to cancel out with just one of
those plus two cosine x squared over X
and I guess we could simplify it even
more as being equal to and we can swap
these everything over x2 cosine of x
squared minus cosine of X and we are
done